right let's get started with
a hose worthy recovery
um webinar delighted
to welcome ben stevenson to the call
and many of you met ben back in january
in his role
for the institute of place management um
since then ben
has taken a leading role in the high
streets task force
and was heavily involved in developing
the task force's
um recovery framework um he is operating
here
as an independent advisor rather than in
that task force
role but it's fantastic to have his
national expertise
online with us tonight ben over to you
ben you're on mute that was a great
start
that's the first time this has happened
so far
so i'm so sorry here we go i have to
re-share my screen
yeah i'm just going to uh remind people
as well
please during the course of this session
um
obviously we want people to contribute
as much as possible
um this is not just about ben talking
it's definitely not just about me
talking
and we would like people to be
polite respectful considerate and where
possible
positive we will have the chat function
operating as well which adrian will be
monitoring
if you would like to talk at any point
then please as quick as possible use the
raise your hands function and i will try
and draw attention to you
as soon as possible um at an appropriate
moment
and if i'm still ignoring you please
just hop back in and ignore me anyway as
i know most of you are fully prepared to
do
and if i could ask you just for the the
sound quality and then most of you have
already muted yourselves
um if you could do that that'd be
fantastic and let's have some
interesting discussions
we're aiming to finish by eight o'clock
at the absolute latest
i'd hope we'd be finished before then
but this is all about
your opinions your thoughts let's get
involved ben
over to you now i can see you're off
mute this time
um thanks very much for that chris i'm
terribly sorry i was gonna meet um
so really kind introduction um really
happy to be here and i hope
that we'll have some interesting
discussion tonight
um chris i think actually you're going
to start anyway aren't you going to give
us a few
um notices about what's going on in the
holesworthy
uh in general um so this is the agenda
for tonight so chris is gonna
um he's going to kick off with that
uh then we're going to do a bit of a
recap on the vital
and viable work that we did about a year
ago um from the ipm the institute for
place management
and that some of you i know were there
um then
i want to talk a little bit and there'll
be plenty of opportunity for you to
depict things around that time
and then we'll talk a little bit about
what's changed
in terms of the national picture with
coronavirus how things have changed
and then also how places are managing
that recovery so every place is
different every place is unique but
but there are some lessons to learn from
that i'm hoping that that will inspire
us a little bit to have a conversation
about how
holdsworthy might uh be sort of
recovering into the future as well
um we uh then actually actually have
that
we we did it we did try the poll for a
couple of
sessions but didn't quite didn't quite
tell us what we needed to know so we
probably will
not do that tonight um but we'll also
talk about the barriers to success
um the action planning process itself so
you know what we're hoping to get out of
this
and how you can um how you can
contribute
so um chris
can we just go we have we haven't got a
slide for you have we but
i think for me the crucial thing about
this conversation
is that a lot of the people on this call
have been involved
in previous discussions
i have many people have spoken to to ben
already
one of the things that fascinates me is
actually how do we get more people
involved in conversations around wholes
worthy how do we get more people
stepping forward and going right you
know what i want to be involved in
creating change
how do we also get a stronger
understanding of what is the change that
people want to be seeing
we know that as mentioned a second ago
in holesworthy
there's only one vacant unit so to a
certain extent
the town centre is meeting the needs
of many parts of our community
but actually whose needs is it not
meeting
how well is it serving our wider
community
and i think that's something that i'm
really keen to explore where can we
grow the impact because if you still
walk around
the town sort of the square in
particular people say to you oh we need
more footfall or we need this oh we need
that
so what is it that we need to be doing
and this is
this session will be contributing
towards the development of
a series of action plans to actually
make sure that
we're not just talking because it feels
like there's been a lot of talk
not enough doing not enough clarity of
what is it that the community of
holesworthy wants to see
coming forward and we're not going to
just gather that
from people who've already been involved
already spoken to ben
i think during the course of this call i
would really value everyone's thoughts
on that one as well
um we've also i'm also delighted that uh
karen rose has joined us uh it was karen
who
ended up um carrying the bat on when
we were exploring uh the rural mobility
fund
and how we could use um some funding to
develop innovation opportunities
within holesworthy in terms of demand
responsive transport
and in particular looking at how we
support our young people
to access the town both for leisure
opportunities
and for future employment opportunities
something that i think is crucial given
the rural isolation of much of the wider
hullsworthy community
on that note fg ben i'm so sorry chris i
thought you were going to do the sort of
the projects that uh
you're going to talk about the the the
projects you've got on the pipeline
files worthy
i think i think let's move on and we'll
kind of um
one of the things that we need to be um
ensuring from tonight
is that there's a real clarity of
actually what is it that josue wants to
see coming through
got it okay right so in that case let me
um
just go through a couple of things i
just wanted to
um tell you a few a few of the things
i've learned um
in terms of the work that i've been
doing over the last few years i've got i
took a 20-year career in
place management and working with places
to
help their economies um thrive
and in this case recover um from you
know at the moment i'm doing quite a lot
of work on coronavirus
and so the the first i wanted to just go
just talk to you in terms of these five
five things i know about places that
every town is unique
obviously you will see that um in a
place like holesworthy because we know
it's unique you see it all
you know you just sort of feel it um but
it doesn't feel like that from many
places
um and i just wanted to mention that
because sometimes you don't necessarily
see that
you don't necessarily see lots of other
places and see how they feel
but um i think we we talked a little bit
before chris
mentioned before about that idea about
holstworthy's independent spirit
you know there aren't loads of change
not big chains in a holesworthy and
in many respects that's really protected
from the sort of ravages of this
clone town idea where you know all
places look the same they've got the
same
um uh tenants you know very risk-averse
landlords that will only ever sign
25-year leases with the cost there
and it's been problematic for a lot of
towns that now really
uh suffering um as you know the
experience of that town has meant that
people have
gone out of town or been driven to
internet shopping
and we've seen a lot of signs in the
last few years that places are beginning
to make a comeback that have got
independent uh shops um
and so as i say it's really good for a
place like holesworthy but it's not also
just about shocked
about um we talk about the idea of
monoculture
in places that have only got retail as a
as their sort of place that you know the
reason why you would go into town and
a lot of places alright identifying
themselves in new ways through events
i know you've got fantastic events in
town and
people's markets you've obviously got a
market um in the evening economy
many respects the way that people live
in town the way that people work
in offices in town is really changing
the the identity of the place
so every town is unique the second
is that change is inevitable and if
necessary
um lots of places have lost their way
particularly those
those that sort of identif identify
through different uh
particular industries or activities that
have sort of fallen away
over the years um actually you've held
onto your capital market i know that a
lot of places
have lost theirs um and and you know
north devon is is full of towns that
used to have a industry that is sort of
falling away a little bit and that means
they they sort of enter a state of
decline
and and even if it feels like nothing
ever changes in holdsworthy
there is always change happening all the
time and actually
you know there there's quite a lot of um
there can be some churn in terms of the
shocks um
and and but i think what what what it
really means is that
you know where people are saying that
the town is going to survive then you
know they'll
survive through the change i think what
is necessary as a plan so that change
could be a bit managed um and so one of
the things that i want to work on
tonight is that
idea that we can come to a bit more of a
vision
so that everyone's facing the same
direction when it comes to
changing holes worthy for the better and
the third is and it's something that i
really want to concentrate when it comes
to
uh the action planning process itself
while we can sort of focus on the sort
of big infrastructural project and i
know that there are some in the pipeline
and some
that a lot of you have talked about so
the viaduct comes to
comes to mind and the places that i've
seen change and the places that i've
seen
change most successfully are the places
where
the community has got gotten together
and done stuff for itself
um and i can think of several examples
um
in holesworthy where that's really put
it on the map
as a place that is seen to come together
and and make it make a real difference
so
we won't we won't ignore those big
infrastructure changes that need to
happen and
you know transport is clearly one of
them there are lots of them
but actually think about what you can do
so when you're coming up with ideas
think about the ideas that that you feel
like you can help deliver
um and number four
not everyone cares about their town so i
think in many ways the message for the
people that are on this call
you're sort of self-selecting local
heroes and champions and that's great
but don't beat yourself up that you
can't necessarily get loads more people
involved it might always feel like
things
fall on your shoulders but uh you know
if that's the case
i'm really hoping that that what we can
do in developing a vision is is inspire
more people to get involved so it's not
always
about um small numbers of people
delivering
just also remember though that some
there there's lots of reasons why people
don't get involved in their place some
economics some
you know about time and it's really
important that
you know you don't beat yourselves up
about that and then
i guess the other thing is you know i
say change is inevitable
and necessary but actually lots of
places aren't changing
we're seeing all sorts of towns up and
down the country that are just sort of
entering this slow decline
where they're really um they're sort of
losing retail over time they're not
really replacing it with anything else
they don't really have a vision
so you know it might be it might be an
option but it's not a great one
if you if you if you do enter a sort of
long-term decline then what that will
mean is less
fewer jobs for your younger people you
know they'll move away
they'll continue to move away and it
will mean less immunity for you as
townsfolk
um you know the whole tourist thing
there's lots of
issues so just going on to the
vitality and viability work that we did
last year and
there were some really interesting
things that came out of that
um it was maybe a little bit uh
expansive
um i've certainly heard that and what i
want to do at the moment is really focus
on
the sort of tangible things that we can
achieve in the future
so vitality all about the life of the
place and viability is about this sort
of long-term sustainability
its ability to be able to attract
investment um into the future
and so just looking at the opportunities
this is what the people that
that um ended that
session said um so
the idea of connecting it all up this
cycle interviewed
lots of ideas about cycling actually
which are pretty heartening and i know
that they
do really well for places all over the
place and
that by dr idea is is a really
interesting one and one i'm sure we'll
get on to tonight
um using what is um unique
to holdsworthy as a as a way to attract
holidaymakers is an interesting one a
lot of people say that people come into
holesworthy
when it's sort of on a rainy day if
they're sort of staying imbued and it's
a bit like
what can you actually use to attract
them beyond that
um it's quirkiness it's it's it's stated
as a historic market town um you know
it's rebranding is a really interesting
one what's its identity
uh so something to think about there um
the idea of pop-up shops and eating out
um
it's the ruin environment of course is
it
is massive and also the opportunity for
new careers so
they're the opportunities you've put in
my s
first and second impressions there are a
couple of things i'd just like to add
to that before we throw it open to
discussion to discussions so
the first is really interesting to see
um
obviously this waitrose landed
like a sort of spaceship on the on the
edge of the center of town pretty much
um it's it's less controversial than
you'd imagine
it would appear and correct me if i'm
wrong really open to discussion on this
one
but it seems to have been a bit of a
welcome driver for football
in some respects um particularly from
outer lying places if you go
from the villages into holesworthy or
waitrose shopping
then um some people continue to come
into town
what can we do to attract more of those
um
the market's obviously also particularly
important not just for its identity as a
place
um but you know it it it's a it's a
historic market town but it also traps
people
in and as far as i understand
in talking to kelly who understands on
the course today you know things have
been picking up a little bit lots more
traders so it'd be really interesting to
see whether that
has um improved has continued to improve
over time
markets are so important but they need
careful curation
they need a consistent offer and they
need a a good experience so they need to
look good you need papers and chairs and
he puts it down
the second thing i knew i was going to
mention this and presumably or
um it's always controversial is this
reliance on cars now i understand
completely that holes worthy is a rural
area
people come into town um by car
and that is just the way that life is
but i i guess i would continue to to
make the point
when you look at pictures like this and
you imagine what the town square would
be like with maybe a few more town
tables and chairs and a few less cars
you know
there is a car park right on the edge of
the square
it's now you know lots of people said
that people would never use it because
it's not free well i understand that's
changed a little bit so
there are you know a couple of hours
free now and
i think the main point i would make
about this and it's the it's the most
important one for people on this call
that see themselves as
the strategic direction setters for
holdsworthy is when you're listening to
in
individual traders who say i want
somebody to
stop immediately outside pop in grab
something and go
that is all very well but there needs to
be a balance between those
the individual traders interests and the
economy of the whole
town so when you're thinking about um
that town square
isn't is it possibly better that people
park a little bit further away and spend
a little bit more time
time going to different places so it's
that idea between a sort of grab-and-go
uh culture economy and a sort of
you know dwell economy where there are a
few more things to do
and a few more tractors and the other
thing just to mention in terms of
of this is that i know that we've got
the um conversations about community
transport to have
maybe that could uh reduce the reliance
on car on the car a little bit okay
so i'm going to stop there the questions
that i've got on the screen here
are uh firstly is this list
is the list still correct are we still
in a sort of postcode landscape where
those opportunities still the right one
for town
the second is if you think about um
what's lacking in the town don't always
think about
you know we need a close shot uh and i
know that people say
we need ladies players we've got
gentlemen's outfitters
it's not all about retail what else is
missing in the town what would really
attract people
holiday makers other markets you know
what would attract people to the town
the third thing is is there anything
that you think
needs to change in a more general sense
uh for the town to thrive and the last
thing is this case of this this issue
about identity
so you say historic market town
there's a market on once a week is that
enough to make it really
sort of is that enough to make the
identity of the town
you know the market central to the
identity
or do you think if you were new to the
town you know
the messaging could be something else
so i'm going to throw it over to
chris now who can manage the sort of
discussion
if any of you would like to put your
hand up to talk about any of this
particularly these issues about identity
be really interested to hear from you
and also if
i don't know adrian if there's anything
in the chat you'd like to mention
so chris as you say i'm the only person
in the chat so far
um i think
for me the final one of those questions
is almost
um could potentially lead into some
interesting places about the first
couple questions
so if you were to step into the
the town centre at the moment as an
outsider for the first time
can anyone happily tell me what do you
think you would think of straight away
what are those first impressions that
the town centre
is giving stephen
not much color rather dull and
lacks a bit of investment okay
would you say a bit of investment what
do we what do we need to be investing in
uh building owners landlords etc uh
painting up the buildings now if you
look at the bazaar that's been done up
recently
it's still in progress but it's already
looking much better than it did before
i think if landlords opted to do pastel
colours of different colours for
different buildings where possible
within regulations and everything
conservation area
i think it would add a lot of brightness
and vibrancy to the town
it would it would change the character
and give it
more positivity i think looking into the
square
okay i know that um i've in the past
tried to persuade some building owners
to to do painting in various different
towns
and it can be a bit of a nightmare i'll
be honest because
we have a lot of building owners who
live away
don't actually care about their
buildings um
but actually i would agree and that
a newly painted building always looks
great
um but anyone else agree about the
sense of okay go for pete
peter on me there we go i always enjoy
saying that line
oh you're still on you're still on
there we go how's that yeah very good
perfect well done
yeah i i agree with stephen actually i
think the the town does need a liquor
paint and um
a bit more weeding it's the um initial
thoughts of people coming into the town
that look around
and think you know wholesome looks a bit
run down now you say about the
buildings being owned by people out of
town well to be fair most of the
buildings in town are owned by
two or three people um torrijona couple
as well
yeah um we have spoken before chris
about
the powers that torridge may or may not
have to force
uh landlords to paint their buildings
two on fire well we haven't got powers
to
force them to paint their buildings it's
uh a section two on five
is where let me see if i'm i'm sure
cancer's hutchings and jones will step
in if i get this wrong
um in fact vanessa probably knows better
than i do as well and
to where the immunity the public
immunity of the building
is impacting negatively
sort of on the the town centre vanessa
is that more or less right
it must be to us like a fairly high
threshold as well
very impressed chris yes it is yeah
thanks vanessa i'd say that
just to say that i i tend to agree i
don't think it's
mostly it's the repair and the painting
shop with some shops that look like they
belong in the 1930s
i'm sorry but they do um and i don't see
necessarily
is there nothing we could do
collectively to do it does it have to be
their landlords we do it or
well i mean that's what i was going to
say kind of actually there are
opportunities for us
if we're talking about kind of gathering
the community together
um working with someone on the
industrial estate for example
um we know we need you'd need permission
from the building owners
but sometimes you just need to start
somewhere it's that first step that's
the crucial thing to
to get going um if only we had someone
for example who
ran a hardware shop or something like
that on the call
um we seem to have um superwoman heaven
kind of reaching in kind of doing a
superpose there
i couldn't say yes i'm just thinking the
place i used to have in town
it was a case of oh the scaffolding cost
too much that was 15 years ago
you know so you think i know that it's
just rotten woods
just it's all a good eight you know out
of sight
of mine but it's not fair on the people
around all the people that are actually
renting these properties yeah
and that's that's the other thing about
kind of other opportunities
um could we somehow find a little bit of
money
work with um a scaffolding supplier if
anyone knew one for example
to go right well actually as a community
here's a special discount offer you can
have this scaffolding for
x because we care about our community
which
i've no doubt would be fantastic
publicity for that um
scaffolding business saying look i
really care about my town center
pete um the town council have got a
little bit of money
aside for town rejuvenation but has
torridge
got any plans to give us any money
towards
town rejuvenation i think pete i'm gonna
be really honest
um i i need to scrap for every penny i
can find
at the moment myself um so
for example kind of all the work that's
just taken place in biddeford came from
a government grant
um but the crucial thing is
having a vision that what
funders and which what torridge will
probably turn around to me and say
no is if we're just looking to kind of
do
piecemeal things oh we'll do a little
bit there and then we're fancy doing
something over here
coming to give me one second vanessa um
what we need to do and i can share it
really easily is actually develop
some kind of a what's called a theory of
change
so actually what is the
the change that we want to be seeing
collectively
not just the people on this call um for
holesworthy so in
kind of uh we've just gone through this
process and bit of one of the things was
about kind of
well-kept buildings one of the things
was about
um seeing more planting not just in the
kind of obvious areas but about
kind of getting it out and about one of
it was about creating
improved um cycling infrastructure to
allow people to get in
and not have to use a car for example to
be able to park their bikes up safely
so it's a case of how to i've just
actually scribbled it down
collectively essentially using ben's
action plan as a great starting point
for conversation
developing that 10 12 15 points
that we all want to be moving towards
that
some things might be torridge trying to
deliver some things might be the town
council
some things might be trying to persuade
people within the community to come
forward
and deliver i think when we've got that
in place then we can definitely start
attracting funding vanessa please stop
me talking
all right now a couple of things um i
was going to mention about sarah chapel
we probably need to get her on board
there's a conservation of because it's a
conservation that's the only thing
i know she's been really helpful to
matthew knew on the designs he did in
this building
yeah the only other thing is some of you
may remember john might
um about uh in 2003 we had foot and
mouth we had
um toys help fund whether when we got
from their foot of mouth
and pam will remember as well actually
as town study
which looked at things like the town
square
with part of its park progesteronization
but looked at the town in general about
the entrance points now i mean i have
got one copy of it
um it was quite a good document i just
thought we could move
that perhaps that that's the first time
i've ever heard about it if i can
yeah i've not heard about this one
either yeah yeah i'd love to see if i
can it would really
help understand you know what was said
before
i only got a paper copy i've not got it
on because it's 2003. i haven't even got
it
on disc on anything i've got scan i can
scan it and send it to me wonderful
thank you
pete thank you for waving around around
thank you i just want to go back to
the um first looks of the town
and um i think weeding is another big
issue and i know the torridge guy and
pete
he's done a great job but he's reduced
his hours down now
to half a day and it's just not enough
time to do all the work that needs to be
done
in the town square is there any chance
we can have
someone from torridge to do full time or
two guys doing half
two half days to help make the town look
nice i think if the town
obviously if the town looks nicer people
are more inclined to come into town if
they're coming to town they're more
inclined to spend money
yeah pete so one of the things um that's
taking off in biddeford is
a sense of community gardening where um
actually finding what people have been
calling neglected pockets and going well
actually
how do we sort of work with torridge
to convert what might be an
underutilized or neglected space
and turn that into something that is
positive
now part of the rationale for that is
about finding ways for people to be
proud of their town to feel engaged and
to feel
like that they've actually contributed
um
so one of the projects led to a group of
brownies park
sort of planting up the back of a car
park and
well what happened then was all those
brownies then came back
with their parents to see the area they
planted up
which naturally brings a lot of people
into the town
and if you've come to see where you've
planted
you're then going to go and wander
around different parts of the town as
well
those brownies also are really proud of
what they've done
and they feel like that they're part of
their town so um
nigel sorry councillor connelly
um thing is so you're paying pete less
money now aren't you
yeah i you know what i have no idea but
yeah you'll pay him less money because
he's doing less hours
so i think as a town we'd appreciate
having torridge
perhaps pay someone to make up those
hours and also can i just add
it's all very well getting the brownies
and scouts and all that to do
um a one-off big thing but it's it's a
it's a constant thing it needs to be
it's it's not a one-off
at all um so this is where we've built
up um community group to actually
keep coming back to it um so we've got
charities involved we've got local
residents involved
to make sure that actually people are
proud of their town um
tdc cleans that every day no no
not at all the tdc guy is yeah okay but
like in terms of this um
this sort of gardening project that's a
community project that comes in kind of
uh normally on a weekly basis
so but yeah i mean i can ask i have no
involvement
with uh the street cleansing or with
kind of
uh pete kind of and his hours being cut
but i can ask the questions
yeah it seems like a very simple thing
you know to ask for to have someone just
do a little bit more
in the town i mean we can all play our
part i try and keep my
shop front very clear um but it's the
little bits that
you know the little side streaks and all
that that really
make holes of e look a bit down and out
really
that's my biggest grind okay and then
it's my list
thank you a pleasure i can ask i i can't
promise anything but i can ask a
question be a pain as usual
good john i think you've got your hand
up
yeah i'm just gonna um just gonna say
like um
we talked about the weeding or that
first i think what you have to be aware
of is who owns what
and it's not quite as straightforward as
saying tourist district council do this
because a lot of it isn't theirs
you know highways is highways um i know
the tower council look at doing some
some weeding and they have to get
permission where they can do it where
they can and can't go
so i think it's a much bigger picture
than just saying
pay this guy some extra hours to do it
or get somebody else
and i agree with it with the self-help
thing there are people out there at the
moment
doing bits and pieces around the town
left their own backs
um you know i know people that have
planted up
plant pots and things that you know they
just walk past and decide they're going
to do it they've cleaned off
signs and things because they just
wanted to do it so
more of a more of a towel approach to
these things would be much
better much more beneficial at the end
of the day torridge is going to have
less money devon county is going to have
less money
so trying to get them to get to get more
money out of them is going to be extra
extra hard
so i think we've got to work as a town
and as a community like you said about
the brownies great idea
there's a lot of people in the town i
think that it will help out with this
kind of thing
that's probably the best way to start
doing these to start up the town we live
in
also i mean from my perspective if
people are involved in it they feel
proud of it
if it's done to them then it's kind of a
a step aside but let somebody else do it
yeah great but i think i know from
conversations with the town council
before
that that's been a sense of uh kind of
oh
people always come to us and expect us
to do it i know at torridge that's
something that we hear
have we in the past maybe kind of
stopped people from coming forward
it's not something i know councillor
jones thank you put your hand up
thank you yeah i mean i i agree with a
lot of what's being said
um i wonder whether it would be worth
speaking to
the secondary school um about these sort
of projects and getting it out there
through them i mean i remember
having a conversation with the um
new i think he's tied as a headmaster of
the school
and it sounded like they wanted to get
involved with these
sort of things um back along so if we're
trying to get this community idea going
the
school is one of the biggest hubs and
well the biggest probably gathering of
people we have in the town so it might
be worth
getting in contact with them and seeing
what what they think about it because
it's by getting
the school involved you get the younger
people involved but then their parents
etc like you said with the
with the brownies so it can sort of grow
outwards from there perhaps
i think that's an absolutely superb
point um it might be slightly difficult
at the current seconds because i know
that um school risk assessments are
things of nightmares
um but actually if we want our next
generation to be coming through and be
proud of their town and to
filter into kind of driving the town
forwards
then it was one thing i mentioned at the
start to what extent are we
providing and meeting needs of that
younger
community um but
yeah really interesting thank you just
as we sort of move on from this
and that's actually stephen we'll ask
you in a second but can i just ask
um whether anyone can answer this
question
do you think that holds worthy is on the
up or is going down do you think that
it's entering
a decline over over years or do you
think that it's getting better and
better so why do you think about that
uh steven what were you going to say um
i was just going to go back to the whole
idea of potentially what was wrapped up
very neatly and tidily is basically
pedestrianizing the town square
a few conversations back um but on the
whole
economic growth of holesworthy i can't
speak for every shop but
over the last 12 months i've seen i've
seen
a massive rise in turnover but i think
that
is one of two things uh mostly a change
of my business model
to adapt to the new economic climate and
then having to re-adapt again because of
covid
um but um back to the
pedestrianizing the town um i think that
would be a mistake
i think that would be a huge mistake
there are a lot of shops
in the town such as willow cots such as
me i'm sure pete as well we've got
elderly customers lifting heavy things
in and out of cars you've got bullet
cops with
customers with fridges tvs you got me
with customers with their pcs and stuff
uh i'm sure pete sells heavy equipment
in his shop and that's you know i'm just
thinking of three shops for example
um you've got the charity shops which
rely on
um downloads and deliveries and things
i think potentially pedestrianizing the
square would be um
would cause a lot of problems how would
you feel about
um a sort of timed closure so for
instance
at the moment it doesn't feel as though
there's in maybe enough going on in the
town square in the evening
what if that was closed for for that
sort of
today so outside so
on on that with closing in the evenings
i don't think there's much you could do
to hold sweaty in the evenings in terms
of bringing people into the square
because
we haven't got the right businesses in
the square that would be open in the
evenings
other than takeaway shops um but there's
a catch
22 with that because um people want to
park outside the takeaway shops which
i've got on the list of things as
one of my bug bears with the square at
the moment is in the evenings after five
o'clock
peak times people park by co-op
and block the square's entrance which um
can be eased with the hsbc road
being open and people you know pass
straight free but
that's another cat of the fish that
we'll probably come to later but
um i don't know i don't i'm not um
closed-minded on that but i think
whatever happens i think whilst
the main shops in the square are trading
there needs to be access to the public
now
you mentioned calls already has a car
park right next to the square that's all
well and good but
um majority of my customers are elderly
and i can't expect
doris to like her you know her 10 kilo
pc
from the car park into the shop and i'm
in the shop on my own so i can't
shut the shop and knock the door and go
collect it from her
um but it's not just my business that
will be impacted by that there are other
businesses in the square like pete's or
willow cots
that will also be impacted by that okay
yeah i i understand that this thing has
come up time and again and
rejected time and again so it's not
something that i want to particularly
push
i suppose the question is you know and
there are there are two things really
one what is the evidence that would even
improve things um
and i think you know every as i say
every place is unique so
it's not though i can give you
incontrovertible evidence that it would
improve
it would improve things i have seen
places that i feel are relatively
similar which are
quite a reliance on the car a sort of um
are you know essentially rural
communities um
and i have seen them turn things around
uh by making their
town squares pedestrianized and you
absolutely take your point about
older people but um as i say
if every place is different it might be
that it doesn't work for you
and this is your plan so you know
can i can i add then if um if we want to
make less reliance on vehicles perhaps
um how's um how's doris going to get
from bradworthy into um
into the town square to bring her laptop
in so i can fix it for her there's
no regular bus service from brad worthy
tollsworthy
yeah so that's a really really good
point and i think we've got somebody on
the call that
is is doing a project on community
transport was that correct
but that was tried um i know it was
tried on a very local scale and
holdsworthy where um
i think it was the transport shop that
was in the square i don't know where
they are now but
um out of their own pockets they tried a
little minibus project to shuttle
old people around who have mobility
issues to bring them into the square
and the service from what i gather it
was um withdrawn because
of lack of use because um
it's there's a whole there's a whole
cultural diff yeah there's a whole
cultural barrier there
you know people with cars they want to
use their cars because it's their
independence
you know these plans work in cities and
different towns but i think wholes
worthy is unique if
you keep on mentioning um you need to
have a unique outlook on it and
sometimes a unique outlook
may be keeping some things in place
whereas other towns move on and adapt
and change
um those particular changes might not
apply to holes worthy
you know a lot of independent people who
live remotely and
have no choice but to use their vehicles
you know it's
stephen i think you've picked up some
really interesting points there and i
think
what we're not in any way saying is
let's completely shut the square off
um i don't know that's something that
any of us want to do
um i think ben's point about partial
kind of
positionalization was more focused for
example on a uh
saturday sort of late afternoon early
evening
kind of uh in a similar way to a lot of
people enjoy
um peter's fair week because actually
it's shut off but i'm aware also that
we've had pete and vanessa kind of
waiting very patiently i think
and julia too yeah okay we've looped
around a couple of times there so anyway
pete then vanessa then julia okay
okay actually i'm going to carry on the
same point as steven to be honest
that's fine i think going back to
economically
the town i think the town is on the up
to fair as
you said before there's only one emperor
two maybe empty units really
um all the other shops are taken
um um the two shops that are empty
are owned by matthew one's being
redeveloped and one's trying to find a
tenant
um so i think i think he'll easily up i
think a few years ago
it was going down i think things are
picking up
i think that's shown through this
lockdown period to be honest
um because most well i think actually
all the traders i've spoken to
have actually done okay really i mean
it's crazy to say that all these big
chains are closing and losing jobs left
right and center
the wholesaler is very independent and
the independents are actually doing
very well um going back to
pedestrianization of the square i
again feel it's a bad uh a bad option
really
um there was talk about closing it in
the evenings actually
in the evenings come half past six seven
o'clock the town is round with cars
absolutely full i don't know where
people are whether that's the
whether that's people who live in town
are parking their cars there
but i mean um co-op always seems busy in
the evening
and the takeaway shops busy of the
evening um
pubs generally are fairly busy
um haltery's got a massive catchment
area
and people want to drive people want to
drive into town
so again what steve said about the lack
of
buses um you know
it is what it is but people want their
independence people want to drive who
want to drive to shops to pick up
whatever they want and then and then go
and that was highlighted again in
lockdown
with the the use of barrels restricting
parking
a lot of people came to me said that
um because of the the lack of parking
they would go elsewhere they'd go to
wherever bnm's imbued or whatever you
know or waitrose
and and use that um uh what other notes
we've got here
you said about saint peter's fair and
closing the
square off on saturday afternoons for
that sort of
atmosphere you find there is quite
i don't say it there can be some unruly
behavior on st peter's fair
i know a few windows have been smashed
in the past and if you pedestrianize
the square you're just you're gonna get
a lot of young people gathering
in the square and that is a recipe for
disaster in my opinion
okay right i'm going to switch over to
vanessa and then julia
and then i believe councillor jones as
well all right um
i'm going to mention pedestrian one last
time and that's it that's fine
the 2003 study only suggested a part
that did say a part pedestrianization
which was a top half the square up to
the pump and it still had the opening
from up to victoria square so just to
confirm that so
nobody said the full square there was
still some parking in there but i think
i mean i don't
i don't live in the town but i've been
associated with town for a long long
time as
a lot of you will know i think it's on
the up or leveled out and it's difficult
cooking their own advice we haven't got
any many empty shops
um and i think we've got a good
opportunity because we've got the count
the town has accepted quite a lot of new
housing into the
area um which is great because it will
allow it to drive i know some people
they'll know they'll new to the era but
there's a lot of people there
that want the move to the tanks they
love it because they can see it's got a
viable
it's a viable town it's got lots of
things they want graham knows
bran will know um but also it's got us
potentially we just need to make sure
they're coming to town that's what i
think anyway
vanessa can i just ask are there any
sort of efforts to communicate with the
people in
the sort of new people and if so what
what is their sort of dialogue between
them
sorry i didn't miss that bit ben you're
a bit quiet what's the
what's the sort of dialogue between the
town and those new people is there is
there sort of ways for them to easily
get involved do they
what what what do you think the best
ones because he's uh he's moved into
town we have
recently only recently done a for a
suggesting people shop locally come into
town use your local market and things
like that
um i think there are some gaps in the
offer for the town
there's some shops we know children's
clothes clothes generally shoes
um but i think there's still so much is
we've got i think we've got another
200 houses coming in to the area over
the next few years
and that's 200 houses but we need to get
them into the town
um i don't know whether it's because
they won't
i don't know really i just think that
there's some opportunity there and we're
we must think about how we get them into
town what the offer is they're missing
so it could be we do some sort of i know
survey to see what people want see what
we can do i don't know it might be a
suggestion
that would be a really interesting thing
a really interesting idea yeah
um councilor jones thank you that's the
other thing where'd we find the shops
as joker said we haven't got and also
it's not just the square it's the whole
of course you know the other the other
businesses around the square
as well yeah so it's not the square
we're talking about this
the town as a whole absolutely it's it's
for me it's how the town centre provides
for the community
and the town centre is not just the
square it is
all the kind of surrounds and how we
will make the most of all of that
so um councillor jones thank you for
wait i'm sorry
apologies julia i almost skipped over
you sorry for
oh thank you yeah i was just going to
pick up on the point that stephen made
about the
town shuttle um junior you're very very
quiet
that's not usually something i'm accused
very rare i'll stand a bit closer is
that any better yeah that's better thank
you
okay that's perhaps just a bit far away
um
so yeah holdsworthy royal community
transport
um trials a town shuttle in holesworthy
um it lasted about three months i
believe was the trial
and this was a sort of circular route
it was going i think
every hour over seven hours over the day
so the route was circled seven times a
day
and it was gonna take people all the way
around so you could
um come into the town center
um out to the doctor's surgery down to
waitrose
i think it actually went out to the
market site as well
and um you know
beforehand all the research suggested
this was going to be extremely popular
and people would like it
it wasn't the case people did not use it
um i'm just off top of my head
um the figures were something like the
the amount of passengers that we needed
um to make it viable
in in a day we were getting in a week or
something like that
you know that's how badly or how poorly
supported it was
um and so it was stopped after the
three-month trial because
of the cost we just couldn't bear the
costs um
and then of course there was a complete
raw outrage and
loads of feedback about how you know we
were going to use that
at some point and how upset people were
that we had
withdrawn it and things like you know
well it's holes whether you should
really have run it for at least 12
months before
you should have made a decision to get
people used to the idea but
unfortunately it wasn't financially
viable to run it for 12 months at such a
loss
so that's you know that that was child
and it was
um it was not found to be popular
the crucial thing there is trialing
actually giving something a go
and we've seen an opportunity to see an
opportunity and i think that's something
that we can look into on a various
different levels if we don't try things
we're never going to find things that
work uh cancer jones apologies i'm sorry
just uh just go for it
so close again i think one of the
um to say that it's been tried and it
failed does not mean mean to say that
um it was the right trial as it as it
were so
community transport is working really
well in rural areas where for instance
it's all it's orderable so you order it
like a cab and then an algorithm figures
out the best way to get around to get
people around so
um it just have a sort of circular route
isn't necessarily working
for the sort of modern way people i
think ben that's where kind of the
hopefully the tie up if we get the
funding essentially between karen
working with julia
um sort of moving forward that's exactly
kind of the conversation that we've
uh had to make sure that i mean the
holdsworthy community transport
partnership does great work
but it's always about how do we do more
how do we meet the needs of more people
um also to make towards the transport
partnership
more efficient and support them so it's
it's definitely something that's a
key conversation going back to what
stephen was saying saying earlier about
kind of
supporting what is potentially a rurally
isolated community in in many ways
um right this time i am going to make it
to councillor jones
stephen i'll come back to a minute
marvellous thank you
um firstly i think the comment that
having a
load of young people coming into the
town is only going to be a
recipe for disaster it's a little bit
unfair on uh
unfair on us younger younger people but
there we are um i think if we actually
look at wholesaling
as a whole i think in terms of the town
i think i think it seems to be the the
actual shops and the the center itself
i'd say is probably
as it was or or maybe slightly improving
but i would say if you look at
holsworthy more sort of
holistically and you look at this sort
of idea of the community of wholesaling
i think it's probably
about the strongest and on the up and
the best it's ever been
i mean when you look at the effort
that's come together with this
um the covered mutual aid group and what
they managed to achieve
actually i would say holds the is
probably
if anything going from going from
strength to strength if you look at it
in those sorts of terms so linking back
to what we said earlier and now is
probably
the the best time to sort of strike
while the iron is hot and try and do
these other
other community-based things which um
we'd already discussed
that's all i had to say yeah i think
it's an absolutely superb point um
it was very noticeable from my
perspective within torridge
how quickly and how efficiently
holdsworthy kicked in
as a community and as a strong
coordinated
effort and it is really about how we
capitalize on that and get those people
to
to stay involved uh stephen i'm going to
come to you and council hutchings has
had his
hand up for a while go for it john um
just want to back up uh what julia said
about the community transport
um the other issue with that trial was
the fact that it had to be
because it was a bus route it was a
timetable route
therefore it had to be um stick to a
timetable but also
um it had the um the bus pass with it
so people with a bus pass only paid like
25 pence or something stupid like that
so that that was a major problem but
they had that wasn't that wasn't
the community transport that was they
because it was a timetabled route they
had to
put that in force so even though the
numbers may have been
you know they weren't i wouldn't say
they're horrendous they weren't
particularly good
but it looked a lot worse because of
what they were actually physically
paying
um so instead of paying one pound fifty
they were paying like 25 30 pence
something like that so that had a
massive impact on it but that was
because it was a timetable group they
had to offer that
um a couple of other things um the bit
about saint peter's fair and unruly
behavior don't agree with that because
actually there's very little um and i
don't
i think we had one window smashed in
about the last five years i think um
and um there was something else but i
can't remember but yeah i agree with the
fact that
the round route maybe wasn't the right
thing to do but at the time that was
that was what was was offered and was a
good idea
um but i think paying for it is
always going to be an issue and who pays
for it yeah
always um stephen thank you for waiting
uh yeah so back to the community
transport thing um
the other issue with people not using
their own vehicles and using public
transport
for the last six months the government
has scared everybody to death that
they're going to
get coronavirus as they travel on buses
and you know
particularly elderly people who are
vulnerable will um
take fear to that make note and that
will stick in their heads that
actually they might get flu instead when
they make it might get common cold
things like that and i just i think
there's been a whole negative impact on
um
public transport usage over the last few
months
i would agree with that one i i do
however know that my uh mother and
father-in-law
were absolutely delighted to get back on
the bus networks
um as they thoroughly enjoy
poodling around on the bus and the
freedom that it gives them
um so i think what i'm reluctant for us
to do is to sweep in
to talk in terms of huge sweeping
generalizations
um we're never withholdsworld they're
going to completely cut out the car
but especially in terms of turrets being
committed to a climate emergency
and also thinking about our young people
and how we can support them
um i know for example people who haven't
been able to get
young people haven't been able to get
jobs in holesworthy despite living in
the community
because they couldn't get in to work at
the right time without kind of
a parent driving them in so it's making
sure that we're
we're creating a almost a blended
solution that works for as many people
as possible
uh john your hand's gone back up again
do you remember that other point
yes i do um it was about pedestrianizing
the square
um and i put a plan several years ago
which was about a herringbone parking
where you actually
didn't close off the whole of the square
you kept you put it one way through the
square
but that top end got closed off um which
and i i understand some of the points
there like steve made earlier on about
shops you know and how do they get you
know people without being able to park
outside the shop
um but actually once two cars are parked
outside the shop you can't get to it
anyway so they've got to park
further away um but i think some sort of
pedestrianising would be a good step
forward although i think it'd be very
controversial
looking at something like you know a
trial where part of it is closed off
might be a way ahead which will keep
everyone happy because you have the
close bit
which makes it a viable space to do
different things in the town
yeah um the other is if you talk about
saturday afternoon if you walk around
holding on saturday it's dead on a
saturday afternoon because a lot of the
shops close at
midday one o'clock on a saturday um and
that you know
without getting all the traders behind
it i know steve tried
opening them later on a saturday at some
point and but you've got to get the
whole
town behind you know opening late it's
like a thursday opening isn't it you
know if you go to plymouth they open
late on a thursday night
um i know we've tried to persuade
shopkeepers to do that in holstein but
nobody a lot of the shops don't seem to
be up for that kind of challenge
again i think steven mentioned catch 22
earlier on um
and the fact that how do you persuade
people to open when there's not a
footfall
and how do you play the football when
there's no one open um stephen
uh i've for the last 12 months i've been
open until four on a saturday i've um
decided to
put my money where my mouth was last
year and um
doing four days saturdays every so often
uh i haven't done it for the last six
months because of covid
i blame everything uncovered like
everybody does but um
i was promoting the free parking in the
car park after one o'clock things like
that trying to encourage
people that actually always worthy is
still open on saturday afternoon but
reality is uh not everybody has joined
on that bandwagon
and until everybody joins in with that
it's um
it feels like it's uh
you know i'm wasting time but i get a
lot of things done so
um can i just ask you um a couple of
questions
what's your business what do you run i
i've got the computer shop in the square
ah perfect okay and the second thing is
so
the car parking is free on saturday
afternoons is it do you see that as
having
had much of an effect in terms of foot
four on saturday afternoons in the
hospital
i think it's a positive idea and i like
the idea and i back it
yeah it's a good way of trying to get
people in on saturday afternoons but
um i think people have got it so stuck
in their head that holes worthy is
closed on saturday afternoon
um but they just avoid the town and um
unfortunately
um you know it's the traders on that one
that have
um have to take the blame people who
have decided that
that's going to be the rule for so long
have
made that the rule so yeah that's his
convention isn't it and do you think
that
do you think that if the two hours was
sort of a different time
that it would be good for holdsworthy
what the uh free parking yeah um
in what sense uh like moving it forward
into the afternoon or moving it back to
the morning well
whenever so do you think two hours free
parking on it at a different time
would be better for sweaty if it was
forward or back or
i don't i think um uh
on a positive note for once actually i
think the afternoon
free parking in memorial car park is
probably at the perfect time because
it's a
time where the towns are quietest and
you're trying to draw people into the
town
with free parking um
so i think that's one thing you guys
have got right there is
trying to bring people into town with
that so i
i don't i can't think of a better time
because if you do it in the morning
people already come in the morning so
you're not encouraging change you're not
encouraging people to spread their
shopping habits throughout the day so i
think
i think that is as good as it can get
so to go back to that sort of chicken
and egg issue
um if there are certain incentives to
get people in then what else can the
town provide so i'm thinking maybe the
market or something are we
are we talking specifically on a
saturday
yes so um
i i don't it's difficult because i've
got so many viewpoints on the whole
pedestrianization of the square
um there are so many different angles on
it
um most of my personal angles are
negative but um i think if um
i think if some places there were more
seating areas and there were more
uh food type businesses restaurants with
outdoor seating areas
on a saturday afternoon um maybe
i don't think kj's would be the right
sort of business to do that but um
you know if there were more eateries
that were open on saturday afternoon in
the square
um with outdoor seating that would have
a positive impact but we don't have
those sort of businesses in the square
therefore
um that doesn't work um
maybe the market could getting could
encourage some street food
traders i
again i um wholeheartedly support the
market
opening on a saturday
other than a wednesday because most
people working habits are at work on a
wednesday
i know that's not a popular opinion
hopefully i didn't get lynched out the
town for that one um
but uh but again
if something happened sorry
that's why you're so imbued at the
moment
with a fast getaway planned as well um
right
i'm aware that and pete's arm is
probably about to fall off because he
has been waving at me for quite a long
time
go for it pete
pete you're on mute again
sorry i've got five points i'm making
even quicker let's go for it
the first point has the free parking
been confirmed by tdc
uh i i'm gonna delegate that response to
cancer's hutchings and jones
so that was that was why i raised my
hand was just to confirm that
the two hours free parking has just been
going to scrutiny but it will go from
the next full
council um and that is uh two hours
the proposal is for two hours free
parking at any time
ah okay there's a bit confusion there
because i was talking about the
afternoon period on saturday
in which past one o'clock you get
complete free parking for the rest of
the day
which is the other point i was going to
make about that is the fact that i don't
think the town promote that enough
because
most people would not know that there's
two hours frequently it's free on us
from saturday until monday morning it's
free
um yeah i agree with that promote it
more
yeah okay um second point
second point quickly um the market
getting shifted to a saturday
great idea i think um i think it would
help people's
buying habits people who work during the
week people
of don't tend to work on the saturday um
so shifting to a saturday great that
leads on to my
next point which is um
i i open until four on a saturday like
steve
now i can see why a lot of shops don't a
lot of shops they're self-employed
they're one-man
bands and they work from at least nine
to five monday to friday
and i can see why they want to do half a
day saturday i can see it you know
people have got children people got
other plans i can see why they do that
you see
so it's all very well you know poo poo
and the traders saying
you should be open well some have got
lives
they can't do it okay um third point
is the part pedestrianization of the
square
it will remove a lot of the free parking
in fact most of it because it would be
all the center
of the square and around the outside
from
steve's shop all the way up to the
odette shop the sugar and ice i think
pete my one point on that one is
um and it's a point that i'm going to
keep coming back to i think this is a
key
point that going back to vanessa's town
survey
that we need to make sure is central to
that
to actually understand actually what do
a lot of people think about this
uh would it be attracting more people if
actually it felt safer
um vanessa don't worry i'm not going to
dump this one completely on your
shoulders i'm going to dump it largely
on adrian and haymitch to work with you
on
and and my my last point and i'll be
quiet
is um uh council hutchins said about a
trial period of
um closing the square
but we we do that every year and say
peter's fair week we do
shut half of the square off and if you
ask any trader
they will say that st peter's fair week
is their worst for turnover
now i know i'll keep going on about the
traders and traders are traders
the thing is if there's no shops and
holes worthy you know the town will die
so we've got to make sure the shops
thrive and then everything comes from
that
it's a really important blend um
making sure that we've got that we're
serving the community
that the traders are thriving and that
it's that kind of happy little sweet
point where we make sure well there's a
super lady again flying in
um so that everyone is
is really working kind of together on it
uh super lady kind of
mayor heaven who kind of flying sorry
can i just ask
do you what else would you say would
make the town thrive
so you know is it just parking issues or
do you think
what else is economically do you think
the town needs
well it's things that are out with our
control really
i think lack of diverse shops is a big
one
but what what can you do you know i know
torah joined a couple of buildings in
the square whether whether they can do
reduced rents
for businesses that aren't in the square
already i don't know it's the
it's a big question and i i don't think
i can answer it to be honest
all right that's fine sorry to be on the
spot sorry chris carry on that's right
council
yeah the mayor keeps flying in sorry
just to say that
going on about some peace is fair and
everything but it's tradition
and housley's got to keep their
traditions
yeah no i i i think for traders
it's a case of well you've got to take
that one because it is tradition it's
like everything
we need to keep those traditions i
completely agree
i was just i was just highlighting the
point of if you
um part shot the square how that will
affect the traders but i
i completely agree i believe and keep
saying peter's fair keep keeping the
market
i completely agree right yes it's
whether for me whether we could utilize
uh say if even if it was every
once a month for example on a saturday
and then how do we organize
some kind of event collectively um
around that once monthly so is it
a case of could we persuade the plow to
be putting on something
could we um be going back to what ben
was saying about
uh speaking to uh street food um
vans to come in there's a really
interesting kind of uh
event that used to take place before um
the pandemic called electric lights down
in tiverton
um that was just a group of street food
vans who came in
and then they started getting bands
involved as well and
all of a sudden you've got a night out
so i think it's having a conversation
going back to again
what would entice the the community to
come in john thank you for waiting
um so we're all talking about
change and we have to change but
actually do we have to change because
we've i've said this all along about
halsey biddeford and tires and holsey is
very unique very different
the truth of it is that what we've got
in holes of the at the moment and i
think a lot of it is probably due to
covid and the results of covid
but what we have in holes at moment
seems to be working
we have very few empty shots the
shopkeepers are saying they're doing
okay
um i've got a pub i'm doing okay um
actually is there anything we need to
physically change is it just the fact of
promoting what we already have
to try and make it more but actually i
know we say we
there's a need for change but is there a
need for change
you know do we keep what we've got but
try and just
promote more one thing we've never
really done in housing we've looked at
ways over the past
you know we looked at things on buses
and things like that um
but it's to promote the fact that we are
a small market town
a very unique place um that
i was looking out the door this morning
there's loads of tourists about this
today you know they're still around
they're still coming into town they're
walking around the town
um that's a good thing so do we actually
have to change anything do we just look
at what we've got
and think right well you know rather
than rather than take that away let's
leave it
um and just promote it um
my other thing going back to the square
um has anyone ever thought about
the fact that car parking also has a
negative
impact on the square because when people
get used to parking in the square
when they drive there and there are no
spaces they drive out and they carry on
even though the car park the main car
park might be half empty
they actually drive in drive around the
square and then drive off again
and that's some that has a negative
impact for us actually julian nodding
away there
the market wednesday is my worst day
of trading in holzley however i'm a firm
believer that the market must stay in
holzley because it's our only usp that
we have
um we need to keep that market it's
doing well at the moment it's getting
bigger
um hopefully that will carry on once
again i think that's a result of covid
because as there are less places to
trade
um trading on a saturday for the market
well i don't think that's vibe that
we're not not viable i don't know what
happened because
the traders that we have come to
wholesale on wednesday this is their day
if you look at saturday markets there
were too many saturday markets where
those traders
already go and trying to get them to
come to wholes where they when we're
competing with the likes of barnstable
market
it's just not going to happen and viewed
on a saturday
so i think that's unless you change the
kind of market we have
then i don't think that will happen um
but i think covid has a lot to answer
for and a lot to me for halsey
quite a lot at the moment to be positive
of because it's meant that people
do actually come into the town more they
do shop local they are using local
businesses
you know i found that people that you
know would probably get in their car and
drive 20 miles to grab something to eat
or drink they're actually staying more
local
and i'm sure that's the case with the
shops i know pizza they have a lockdown
you know very busy along with the post
offices and places like that
because actually people are traveling
further distances so the car park is
even more important than ever
but that square i still you know there
could be something to talk about that
and the other thing is stop the traders
parking in the square to free up for
people that actually want to come and
shop
and that is a direct dig at certain
people
and john really really important point
on
in terms of does do we have to change
you absolutely do not need to change if
you don't you know if
if it's not necessary so the question
here is there anything that needs to
change for the town to thrive
if the place continues to thrive then
there is no need for change but i guess
there are two points to make here
the first is change is happening anyway
and it continues you know
across the country retail is changing
the patterns of retail are changing
um most places in most places retail is
contracting and it's being replaced by
other things and that will happen
eventually in all places so you know
change is happening anyway and
i guess the second point is you have to
be really really sure that you're
speaking for everyone when you say that
nothing needs to change because
there are you know you have to consider
that
broad economic issues around are there
enough jobs for young people
you know is there you know is is is
everyone being served by the status quo
essentially
and so i guess i guess those
questions are questions that that you as
a town need to ask yourself
as you think about what the vision needs
to be going forward yes you don't have
to change
but you know these are important
questions um
quicker come to nigel who i believe um
probably wanted to support a sense of uh
selling the town better uh yeah like
john was saying about
the time we haven't got a dedicated
group or committee
that actually their only focus is
promoting the town i said that to ben
the other day that
i think that's one thing we could think
about is having a dedicated group
that so focuses promoting the town not
just the times square
all of the town yeah it's really
interesting you say that and
i think tourington town council have got
their first uh
marketing group meeting at the end of
this month and biddeford
town council has just started their own
marketing group
um so it's initially i mean this could
be a council-led initiative sure but it
needs to involve it can't just be a
council thing
that's exactly what i was about to say
as well that kind of
the really pleasing thing for me is that
both of those projects
um have gone right well we've got to
call a few people from the council
but in the nicest way if it's just from
a council no one's going to listen
um it needs to come from kind of a
broader spectrum
of people now i'm aware as well and i'm
not going to apply any pressure on
people
i'm aware that it's ten to eight that
we've this conversation has flown past
thank you so much
um but unusually graham's been very
quiet
uh pam as pam sue and joe have all sat
there uh very quietly as says bridget
would any of you kind of um like to
sort of contribute at all i'm not going
to force you to
um but have you got any responses to any
things that have been picked up pam you
look like you've lent forward
there we go yeah i was just gonna unmute
myself um
well my um drum to bang is
uh the cycle way down to bude um
[Music]
i was at um on the camel trail um
just a couple of weekends ago um
and you only got to see what that's done
for way bridge
um and it
it would definitely enhance um
economic regeneration for hosworthy if
the cycleway was ever able to be opened
up
down debuted um because if if the
weather's not
great for a day on the beach um
it's very doable to bimble up to jose
eight and a half nine miles and bimble
back
um whereas the route the other way
to sort of bit of a bit of it and
barnstable it's it's a much longer
schlep so
um i think if you look at how busy it is
between
um say torrington and biddeford or
biddeford and insto along the tarka
trail
and you can see on those as you say
reasonable days
i know that i do with my family go up
and down um
i i spoke to council hatchings about
this one this morning
um adrian is getting involved in a lot
of cycling infrastructure
it is a complicated one though
given the nature of ownership on that
one yeah adrian's going to get briefed
on it in the very near future because
we need to make sure that we have our
eyes open for where an opportunity could
come with on that one
so i mean nude is is the next place to
be developed up that coast um you know
padstow
um rock um port isaac
all those areas are sort of getting
saturated
and um it's moving further north and um
you know it's it's a no-brainer in my
mind
if if we could ever make it happen i
think we'd all be delighted and
joe you lent forward a second ago and
smiled as if you kind of wanted to get
involved
i don't feel enforcing you in any way
um i wasn't going to weigh in on the on
the bike thing but i think
that pete's kind of right about a
variety of shops will help
but it's very difficult to achieve you
just kind of have to wait for the
opportunity really
um but i do think that
the absence of ladies clothes shouldn't
hardly be underplayed
because that was the reason for
some people to come into town the
factory shop might have had its flaws
but
it was very good for pretty much
anything you wanted and that did
encourage people into town more probably
than bargain buys does
and also i think coming back to our
favorite point of pedestrianization
look at what happened to launching i
don't think you want to go there there's
it's all very well part pedestrianizing
or pedestrianizing it and saying well
we're going to have good events now but
unless you have a firm
program of events with uptake it's
pointless because people will just never
come into town again
yeah i think that's a fantastic point in
terms of having a committed program
and getting those partners on board for
that regular programming
to make sure that people actually know
what's going to happen and when
because otherwise it very quickly
becomes oh well i've got time to
organize something this month
and then it just dies um really good
point um uh
graham sue bridget and mary any kind of
desire to
contribute honestly not feel
bridget yeah i just want to i'm not
everybody knows me but i'm
a community developer employed by ttvs
under the one northern devon umbrella um
if there's anything
you're talking earlier about the
gardening and things like that
and getting the community groups
involved um
i'm happy to use some of my time to help
sort of coordinate anything like that
anything's got
a health and well-being slant to it
i'm more than happy to sort of you know
help with the coordination of that if
it's appropriate
fantastic thank you very much bridget i
think uh that would be really
appreciated
um okay ben i'm also aware that kind of
uh
a lot of the input that you wanted to to
add
has gone completely out the window but i
think it's been a fascinating discussion
very much so no it's about it's about
their input rather than mine but
um so you've been really useful thank
you uh
right john does that hand back up again
um i just want to throw something in the
mix about the square
for not last year but several years
before that devon county council wanted
to bring in
pay meters for the square we fought
against it and i can see that coming
back
very soon um that's something we're
going to need to
to look at um and work out but i think
that's
devon county council going to be trying
to get every penny they possibly can i
think that's going to come back and rear
its head very very soon
and just saying for people to be aware
of i think yeah i think the the issue
connected to that as well is that
um our contacts who's been working with
us
off and on as in james anstey at devon
highways
is no longer in that role so we no
longer have a contact point
um especially one who knows about these
ongoing discussions
um i think that's a very astute point
unfortunately
um right i think it's now about three
minutes
to eight so has anyone got any
final last points that they would
desperately like to raise
in which case i'm going to hand over to
ben
basically to make sure that you've all
got his contact details
and can pester him from now on
this is all the content you missed
imagine
poor you i'd say let me just bring this
up
uh i hope you can see that so so yeah so
it's basically
another two or three weeks that i've got
to
write this action plan it's it's not a
massive report that gathers dust on the
shelf
it's uh it's going to be quick and dirty
reading about quite a lot of the things
that you said to me as
as i've mentioned you know i want it to
be challenging but i don't want it to be
something that is never going to get
delivered
um and so if you've got any specific
points you'd like to make that you don't
feel like you've got across
if you think there's other people that i
need to speak to that i haven't yet
spoken to
um and if you feel like there's a sort
of voice that hasn't been put yet
um you know the voice of of any specific
kinds of residents or
anyone else that or young people that i
haven't managed to speak to yet
and i'd really be grateful to hear that
sort of diversity of opinion
and so put them in touch with me if you
can and and then basically once i've
written this
uh action plan uh it
will have sort of a month to consult on
it um and you can
you can uh debate it among yourselves
and figure out which books you want to
keep and which bits you want to get rid
of
and but apart from that um that's it for
this evening i think so really grateful
uh for your time thank you ben thank you
so much i think from my perspective
and that's been a really interesting
discussion i think
my goal is from this is that
when ben sort of collates these opinions
into
a sense of action plan that's something
that we can utilize for example for
a survey to kind of actually bring more
opinions in
and looping back round to my very first
point try and see
if we can get a stronger sense of
what is the desire of the community
going back to john
which point where do we want change
where do actually we don't want change
at all um and try and create that sense
of
a vision for us all to move towards
during the next couple years
um guys thank you so so much for giving
up your wednesday evening
it really is appreciated especially as i
know that a lot of you do a huge amount
of the town
um already and are very busy individuals
thank you so much and i look forward to
catching up with you all again soon